it's been over a month since the
shooting at shanghai plaza in chinatown
a waiter was shot multiple times at
shanghai taste restaurant and is still
recovering in the hospital tonight
madison kimbrough spoke with employees
and shop owners at the plaza to see if
security has changed since then she
joins us live with the latest tonight
madison
many businesses have changed the way
they operate and implemented change
within their business since the shooting
that happened on december 20 and some
employees tell me they still feel
uncertain about their safety here at the
plaza
i don't really feel safe at all in here
actually employees and staff at shanghai
plaza are expressing safety concerns
after a month has gone by since the
shooting at shanghai taste restaurant on
december 20th chang on wang a waiter at
shanghai taste was working late cleaning
the restaurant when he was shot 11 times
just before 3 a.m while mr wang survived
the owners of shanghai taste say mr wang
has a long road back to recovery the
suspect 23-year-old rashawn gaston
anderson is now in custody many
employees like joanne mamek who works at
t mason says that security at the plaza
is inadequate i already feel like
it's not safe because there's i don't
really see a lot of security walking
around
i'm not even sure if security even
exists here at all i park at the back
and there's like no lighting at the back
right now jay park owner of the paleta
bar says his staff has implemented the
buddy system when going out at night
instead of like you know having one
person throwing away the trash now like
we have like two people just for safe
for the employee staff however there are
some restaurant owners who feel that
this shooting was an isolated incident
and they aren't too concerned moving
forward i don't worry about my safety in
this mall and like i say you know i
don't
they're not going to be any changes
you know as far as operating business
and you know dealing with customers
we reached out to the owner of the
shanghai plaza who said his legal team
did not want him to comment reporting
live at shanghai plaza madison kimbrough
live local now